[Musique]
afin d'accompagner le développement du
quartier de l'École polytechnique le PA
Paris Saclay et réalise pour le compte
de la ville de Palaiseau le futur groupe
scolaire du quartier c'est un projet qui
est inscrit au programme des équipements
publics de la ZAC afin d'accompagner les
besoins générés par l'arrivée des
nouvelles familles sur le quartier à
l'horizon 2025 l'équipement comprend
donc un groupe scolaire de 22 classes 12
classes élémentaires 8 classes
maternelles et deux classes rotules donc
des classes qui sont qui sont là pour en
faire face à l'évolution du besoin et on
a également au sein de cet équipement un
certain nombre de programmes mutualisés
que sont notamment un espace de
restauration de l'accueil périscolaire
un gymnase en complémentarité avec un
pôle sportif de quartier qui ont réalise
également à proximité directe de ce
groupe scolaire le futur équipement
sportif est réalisé dans ce qu'on
appelle le secteur sud du quartier à
proximité de la toute nouvelle résidence
étudiante à cœur house
c'est également un secteur qui donc est
situé à proximité directe des coteaux
boisés outre les enjeux de polyvalence
et d'évolutivité qui auxquelles le
projet doit répondre une attention toute
particulière et portée sur la qualité
des espaces extérieurs support de
biodiversité en connexion directe avec
les lisières du plateau toutes proches
en effet tous les espaces extérieurs
donc les cours de la maternelle en
rez-de-chaussée de l'élémentaire à
l'étage mais également les toitures
végétalisées et le jardin potager tous
ces éléments doivent répondre à une
démarche de cour oasis permettant à la
fois de lutter contre les îlots de
chaleur mais également de pouvoir offrir
de véritables d'espaces pédagogiques
appropriable par les élèves les équipes
enseignantes et les familles
il y avait vraiment un bâtiment qui
avait conscience de s'implanter dans son
territoire et c'était ce qui nous
intéressait dans ce projet il est
composé à la fois des maternelle et
d'une école élémentaire au
rez-de-chaussée on retrouve l'école
maternelle qui a sa cour ses animaux et
à l'étage sur un seul niveau l'école
élémentaire avec également sa cour en
étage cette lecture simple permet d'un
point de vue aussi fonctionnel mais
également esthétique où on va dire
architectural d'avoir une lecture claire
de où sont situés les salles de classe
ou sont situées les salles de vie les
cantines et tous les espaces qui font ce
projet finalement l'idée de ce projet
c'est d'avoir à la fois un rapport à la
ville à l'urbanité et également la place
qui lui fait face mais aussi au paysage
de la lisière et notamment avec cette
courroie qui se relie à celle là ce
projet il permet en fait de relier la
ville à la lisière et d'avoir un lien et
une connexion permanente entre l'école
et son extérieur
le bâtiment la particularité d'avoir 60%
de sa structure en bois ce qui est un
défi conséquent quand on sait la
complicité d'avoir des cours d'étages en
soccer bois et donc tout ce travail est
mené de front pour justement relier les
complexités techniques qu'il y a avec la
construction bois avec justement ce
sujet des cours la végétalisation et des
cours oasis le projet s'inscrira
également dans une démarche de label BDF
donc bâtiment francilien durable et
c'est versura obtenir tous les labels
environnementaux nécessaires pour un
groupe scolaire remarquable et actuel